Julia mamani resultó herida iba a pagar
los servicios y se encontró una protesta
fue golpeada y disparada
me ha chocado y a este lo vamos no sé
su hija Marta mamaniz muestra los vídeos
en su teléfono las mujeres aymaras
esperan organizarse para ir a Lima
nosotros
este gobierno Usurpadora puede tratar de
esa manera a nuestros compatriotas
Así quedó la comisaría de policía de
Juli en la región sureña de puno el
incendio fue la respuesta de los
manifestantes al uso de armas de fuego
de la policía para dispersar la marcha
violencia en las protestas con especial
dureza en el sur del país pero también
en Lima la capital donde manifestantes
salieron el sábado a las calles
no nos vamos a cansar los peruanos
tenemos sangre inca y vamos a seguir
luchando somos chancas y no nos vamos a
chupar ante ella y ante nadie vamos a
seguir si es para morir moriremos
luchando nuestra patria el martes se
cumplen tres meses desde que Dina
boluarte fuese proclamada presidenta ese
mismo día tendrá que declarar ante la
fiscalía que busca determinar su
responsabilidad en las 60 muertes
ocurridas durante las protestas esto por
la destitución y posterior detención de
Pedro Castillo quien había tratado de
disolver El Congreso Un gobierno de
emergencia